on va passer maintenant pour moi c'est
au dessus et si on se rencontrer on va
rencontrer dans un instant Malaga un
flambeur et mythomane professionnel on
l'adore hier soir on vous rappelle le
principe donc de cette émission ils se
sont rencontrés sur les réseaux sociaux
entretiennent depuis des mois voire des
années une relation virtuelle pour la
première fois ils vont se rencontrer
devant les caméras hier soir il y avait
encore des persos et des histoires de
ouf je vous le dis c'était incroyable
hier soir on va revenir sur tout ça et
avec ceux qui ont marqué l'histoire hier
Malaga Mélissa et Tayara
Malaga donc Malaga et Mélissa le couple
phare de l'épisode d'hier on a donc
découvert Malaga qui a cartonné sur les
réseaux pour son profil un peu
particulier
ils disent que je suis l'arnaqueur de
tinder
sur les réseaux sociaux je suis malade
je suis influenceur je pose des photos
avec des grosses voitures des gros 4 4
noirs j'ai un train de vie voyage tout
le temps je prends des fringues des
grandes marques super cher j'ai des
appartements plusieurs à Paris plusieurs
à Marseille comme je crois toi des
personnalités qui ont beaucoup d'argent
tout le monde croit que j'ai été dosé
[Musique]
alors
Malaga et Mélissa ça va ça va et toi
alors nous a tué un frère c'est vrai
franchement hier tu as tout explosé j'ai
adoré j'ai adoré les liens ça va alors
on va revoir Malaga tu as une vie de
rêve
il y avait un peu en Guy sous roche tu
as un peu mytho à Mélissa ouais
légèrement un petit peu ouais a commencé
par les villes où tu habites regardez
Dubaï j'ai fait
la France j'ai fait les Etats-Unis tu as
vu c'est un truc que j'ai pas fait j'ai
envie de faire
tu as raison c'est cool
alors voilà voilà
donc toi
tu savais que tu allais faire que des
Tommy en fait en fait à la base non je
savais pas que j'allais faire que des
Tommy maintenant le truc c'est que j'ai
été pris dans un engrenage ouais parce
que cette villa bah je la vivais mais
c'était pas la mienne d'accord dans le
sens où j'étais vraiment à Dubaï j'ai
j'avais vraiment un ces véhicules en ma
possession parce que c'était des prêts
d'amis qui eux ont réellement cette
villa et du coup les taux et c'est et
c'est resserré sur moi et j'ai été pris
à mon propre jeu bien sûr alors deuxième
mytho que tu as fait on m'a dit aussi
que tu étais rentier c'est une deuxième
vidéo que tu as raconté à Mélissa
regardez
ce que je vise là-bas c'est vraiment les
personnes on va dire qu'ils sont assez
aisés sur qui payent des coachs privés
tu te déplaces chez eux tu fais des
trucs et tout il y a un marché de ouf à
prendre là-bas
conciergerie et toute ma vie
les coaching tu vois sont en cours il y
avait toujours il y a toujours les
agences il y a toujours les rentes et
tout je sais j'ai la boîte de location
de voiture j'ai pas le 4x4 qui est
rentré là il y a trois semaines un truc
comme ça
alors
mais tu as aussi menti sur le nombre de
tes propriétés
en fait au début je vais au feeling
après je vois que c'est de plus en plus
chaud et là je me mets à préparer les
mythos ça y est là donc tu es parti là
en fait je sais plus comment il
s'appelle je sais pas quel âge il a je
sais plus
je sais pas quoi
vous parliez depuis combien de temps sur
les réseaux
kiffes un peu bah quand tu parles avec
quelqu'un pendant trois mois que je
partage des vidéos des FaceTime des
nananas à un moment donné tu t'attaches
c'est normal et alors et après bah au
final je t'attache à rien à du vent
on va voir là
à côté de ça j'ai quelques placements à
gauche à droite j'ai deux appartements
ok on est un troisième là qui est en
cours de construction qui a je crois
encore six mois d'attente donc cela ils
sont mis sur une location OK
je me suis je me suis juste servi de la
réalité je l'ai un peu un petit peu
extrapoler
c'est un joli vais les choses et
moi moi je suis alors on va en parler
dans un instant avec Mélissa vous allez
voir ce qui s'est passé après parce que
tu lui as tout déballé après tu lui as
dit que c'était un mython va en parler
dans un instant Mélissa et Malaga ils
sont parlé pendant trois mois deux mois
ouais 3 mois et donc tu étais toute
contente de le rencontrer et alors une
fois que tu l'as rencontré
déjà je suis contente déjà physiquement
c'est mon si j'ai une plaie et tout et
après ben plus le deites avant c'est
plus ça tourne au fiasco du coup
et voilà la suite on la connaît tous
alors
on l'a dit un Malaga enchaîné les mythos
et à un moment le mytho était tellement
gros que tu as fini par tout avouer à
Mélissa tu as tout déballé ça a fait
l'effet d'une bombe
tu vois à Dubaï avec des grosses
voitures que tu vois dans tous ces beaux
hôtels tout ces appartements ces trucs
et tout en vrai de vrai c'est pas moi si
tu veux en fait quand je suis resté à
Dubaï les 5 mois que je t'ai raconté
est-ce que tu as pu voir sur mon
Instagram c'est tes pas chez moi
l'appartement à 36e étage avec la vue
sur la Tour Eiffel c'était c'était une
location je pouvais même pas te ramener
dans un appartement parce que le sol que
j'ai c'est une dépendance que j'ai fait
construire dans le pavillon de mes
parents
[Musique]
après c'est pas grave bah non parce que
ça veut dire pendant 3 mois je parle à
quelqu'un qui qui mentait donc c'est pas
possible ça veut dire que quoi je vais
continuer à parler avec lui je vais je
vais me douter de tout ce qui va me dire
c'est pas possible
pourquoi il ne manque que sur de
l'argent ça veut dire que vraiment
est-ce que toi tu as montré un signe
comme quoi l'argent ça t'intéressait et
tu l'as mis assez cure et du coup il est
obligé de te mentir sur de l'argent
pourquoi il te manque que sur de
l'argent le truc c'est qu'il a pas fait
qu'avec moi c'est qu'il a fait que
beaucoup de filles mais donc ça veut
dire que c'est même pas moi le problème
mais j'ai une question pour Mélissa et
si vous n'ont pas fait passer pour une
femme intéressée parce que pas de dire
elle rêve de rencontrer un homme riche
etc
il me fait pas ça pour une fille
intéressée alors que moi déjà j'ai
jamais rien montré par rapport à ça je
suis filtrée simple je me lève tous les
matins pour aller au travail je suis pas
qu'un influenceuse
c'est pas de la marque et voilà donc
j'ai je montre pas quelque chose enfin
une image comme ça donc je sais pas
compris je pense que ça manque de
confiance que pour lui pour attirer des
filles bah il faut avoir une certaine
sécurité je sais pas je sais pas
tu regrettes ou pas non je regrette pas
du tout si c'est à refaire la même et si
il faut honnête je suis quelqu'un de
très honnête
moi j'ai non mais c'est vrai parce que
il y a la fin des choses il y a la part
des choses
j'ai menti
j'ai menti pour lui plaire donc je vais
reprendre exactement les termes dont on
parle il y avait peut-être un manque de
confiance en en moi ça c'est vrai parce
que faut savoir que je mens pas depuis
hier bien évidemment elle c'est la fille
à qui j'ai décidé de tout avouer mais
j'ai j'ai quand même réussi pas mal de
stratagèmes avec d'autres filles
auparavant et c'est parce que j'avais
j'avais un manque de confiance en moi je
n'avais pas ce corps-là j'avais 15 kilos
de plus je côtoyais au quotidien il faut
savoir au quotidien des personnalités
qui étaient très aisés d'accord donc je
suis invité à des bookings ils sont tous
zappés de la tête aux pieds grosse
montre grosse voiture moi je suis là je
les regarde donc forcément je me fais
prendre au jeu donc je rentre dans cet
engrenage là d'accord et en les voyant
et je me dis mais j'aimerais bien avoir
cette vie là c'est ça et je me fais
prendre à à mon propre piège avec elle
et donc au final c'est une manière pour
moi de me déguiser et de me donner
confiance en moi mais je regrette pas
parce que au final le fait de d'être
passé aux aveux c'est aussi la preuve
que pour moi aujourd'hui j'ai confiance
en moi tu vois je m'en veux même c'est
qu'un jour l'autre j'allais le savoir
j'allais bien la voir ta Clio
bien sûr bien évidemment
elle l'aurait su mais est-ce que tu veux
pas
avoué
si tu avais des débuts
en fait je lui ai parlé parce qu'au
final si je voulais vraiment quelque
chose de lui de matériel j'aurais pas
attendu trois mois à parler avec lui à
part mon temps en fait dans ce cas-là je
le vois je achète-moi un sac ok mais là
je l'ai pas fait
que moi moi je tu te vois pas tu te vois
pas être avec lui mais c'est trop tard
il y a trop de mensonges
partez d'une feuille blanche je suis
contente qu'il l'ait fait avec moi parce
que il aurait pu ne pas le faire et
toujours
à la globe en plus moi je trouve que tu
es mieux que sur les sur les vidéos
grâce
à toi
je rigole non non mais ça m'a ça m'a
fait quand même d'appel on m'a touché
après chaque dépression
Malaga moi je trouve merci ouais
franchement je trouve que c'est génial
ce que vous avez fait parce que je
trouve qu'on utilise beaucoup les
réseaux et on en parle nous ici beaucoup
pour s'inventer une vie les chiens sont
obsédés par les filtres d'ailleurs dans
les missions tout elles arrivent en
disant ça va tu es pas trop déçu par mes
filtres et tout mais même moi la
première on enlève les séries non voilà
et du coup je trouve que c'est vache
pour bien parce que vous êtes un peu un
sort de lanceur d'alerte aujourd'hui
c'est ça le
mecs
mais on a on a 50 ans on a des vieux
cons je vous dis juste que les jeunes
aujourd'hui ils se rencontrent via les
réseaux sociaux SDM après ils se racine
comme ça non je trouve que c'est bien
parce que ça veut dire que les filles
elles vont dire bah ouais mais tout ce
qu'on me dit tout ce qu'on me dit quand
je rencontre quelqu'un sur les réseaux
sociaux ça n'est pas vrai il faut que je
fasse attention il y a des petits
signaux comme ça depuis la diffusion je
me fais harceler par tous les bluffeurs
de France là-bas non ça y est Instagram
[Rires]
c'est le c'est la dans
[Musique]
parce que comme je m'inventais des vies
c'est la Fame et c'était mon mon surnom
de l'influenceur
je ne suis jamais allé
[Rires]
je vous ai
[Applaudissements]
la viande ça donne
la parole dans 2 minutes Perpignan et
donc tu es jamais allé à Malaga c'est
oui je me suis inventé une vie de de
menteur qui est parce que c'est la Jet 7
un peu Malaga et toi et comme dit
pourquoi Malaga je suis parti en
vacances là-bas j'ai tellement aimé que
c'est devenu mon surnom sur les réseaux
sociaux ça part juste de là je me suis
jamais oui bien sûr Rafik
c'est une bonne trouvaille
bien sûr
dans l'émission tu te compare à
l'arnaqueur de tinder c'est quoi le plus
gros mytho que tu aies fait une meuf je
peux j'ai vraiment
une meuf que j'étais fils d'héritier et
que mon arrière grand-père avait donné à
toute une génération qui est maintenant
la mienne beaucoup de bien sur Dubaï
mais que en fait je faisais exprès de
dire que j'arrive pas d'argent à
certaines personnes parce que j'étais
multimillionnaire mais ça ça a mis
tellement
à prendre forme
en fait que tous les stratagèmes je les
travaille c'est du boulot aller chercher
non mais je parle vraiment sérieux
vraiment je vous donne un exemple
typique d'une soirée la soirée va durer
quatre heures oui je prends ma petite
Clio voilà je vais à l'agence
dans une Rolls mais et j'arrive j'arrive
à l'agence de location je prends le
véhicule de mon ami ok il faut aller
chercher les filles faut aller à la
soirée Soirée bah voilà j'ai la chance
d'avoir un oncle qui est en
établissement je ne paie même pas en
soirée non plus et sur les réseaux je
montre que ce que je veux un snap c'est
10 secondes voir une minute une journée
c'est 24 heures et quand on voit que ça
marche et que ça prend et bah on
continue voilà exactement on va faire du
décor 80% des influenceuses mitonnes
juste un truc quand moi je vois que et
j'en connais mais je donnerai pas de nom
des influenceurs qui ont réellement de
l'argent eux-mêmes portes des répliques
et des choses comme ça c'est les
premiers à aller faire des stories dans
des magasins de luxe quand ils achètent
chez une chemise il faut il reste 15
minutes dans le magasin ils arrivent à
faire 20 minutes de story mais ils ont
des montres à 400000 euros au poignet
bizarrement le il se nappe pas chez le
bijoutier c'est quand même bizarre et
c'est là où je vais en venir j'ai fait
ce que personne n'a fait montrer une
réalité des réseaux alors
aujourd'hui est-ce que tu as trouvé
l'amour non toujours pas non tu habites
où toi à Paris 26 ans 26 ans tu as
toujours pas trouvé l'amour
[Applaudissements]